Continental Tire Coaches Corner
Continental Tire works hard to give you
the technology driven award-winning
product surpassing all the competition
they want you the driver to have the
traction performance and comfort that
you require on the road that your
travels may take you we love Continental
Tire proud supporter college basketball
for more information visit Continental
Tire dot-com he's George Karl he has
written a book George a longtime NBA
coach 27 years in the NBA do you even
remember how many years you don't I've
never done ok I know you got eleven
thousand hundred and seventy five wins
over those 27 years but George has
written a new book called furious George
my 40 years surviving NBA divas clueless
GM's poor shot selection now available
online and wherever books are sold
whose idea was it to write the book Curt
Samson so he's your coal co-author yeah
Curt and I like golf together a lot in
the summertime but been friends for over
20 years and he's a writer he's written
a lot of golf books mm-hmm
and we're playing golf hanging out when
it was actually probably after the time
I was working at ESPN and you know we
just kind of chatted about the stories
of the MBA and you know the history of
my history is so much of the MBA I
learned you know talking basketball at
breakfast talking basketball at lunch
talking basketball with chicken wings
and beer you know in my times with Don
Nelson and Rick Majerus and Dell Harris
and you know Bernie Bickerstaff guys
like that I mean the interaction of your
feelings with another coach's feelings
and then the play of that topic is a big
part I think of I think what I learned
how I learned a game and also a part I
think of the game that sometimes we've
lost now the guy the game has gotten so
big we don't stay we don't hang out very
much anymore it's it's it's real your
team and your staff and your
organization that's you're with them all
the time and you know when we got to
charter flights we never stayed
overnight in the city so that was kind
of where
the conversation after a game and you
want and you went out and talked trash
and had fun anything off limits in the
book yeah I mean I think you know as a
coach you have a filter on all the time
yes you know your filter is you know the
to do what is right to them in the media
that will try to enhance him and then
power your basketball team and so when
you have situations you know you're
dancing a little bit you know for the
last two or three years you know I
wasn't dancing and and the book was
written probably most of the book was
written before I went to Sacramento you
know and so situation is you know I
think a book has to have an opinion it
has seven has to have my feelings in it
and maybe I you know maybe I crossed the
line I don't know that's what people
have been saying but in my sense you
know I've been probably too honest most
of my life anyways and I've always stuck
my foot in my mouth that's who I am a
little bit and we'll see how it goes
would you have written this book if I
gave you a do-over I think that question
is more important to ask when all this
is done oh okay because you've gotten
feedback from you know Kenya Martin and
Carmelo Anthony those topics I think
most of the reaction right now is on
excerpts yes and I think reading the
book if you read the book you'll get a
different flow is there anything out of
context though with what you said about
Carmelo Anthony and Kenyon Martin no you
got the only thing I've said about you
know I think I said the Fatherhood sing
very poorly in the book and you know
because I don't I don't I never wanted
to go there other than as a coach you
you talk about everything as a coaching
staff you're trying to do anything to
help anybody it's stronger get better
get tougher learn faster you know you're
every player on your team you're
managing what can we do to help that
person but do you think not having
father's hurt Kenyon Martin and Carmelo
Anthony as players I can't I can't
answer that specifically but I I think
the mound of money the yunxi
are being given and the opportunities
and situations they are being put in at
age 19 20 21 even 22 23 are difficult
and if if you would have given me that
opportunity I probably would have made a
lot of mistakes I mean give me an
example of what you see with not being
able to handle their money
what gives specific incidents where
somebody I know any specific instance
with Carmela or Kenyon but otherwise I
think we know a lot of situations were
financial difficulties of our pro
athletes have been been pretty well
documented along the way
you know it was good to have my father
it was good to have Coach Smith when I
didn't feel good I mean my first year in
wig if I didn't have coach Smith I
probably would have ran away you know
because I you know he was the guy that
was walking me through something some of
the things I were going through could
college staying in college helped this
situation like it can I don't think it
could hurt but but can it help these
kids staying and having a father figure
or somebody helping them understand
finance I understand both sides of the
argument but for me I would say yes I
mean I don't know the details of
football and basketball but I heard
baseball has you can come out of high
school or you can say you go in you guys
stay through most of your sports you can
come out of high school golf you can and
tennis you can and hockey you can it's
baseball if you go to college if you
accepts a scholarship you got to stay
three I think that'd be a win-win for
propel pro coaches and college coaches
but you know I don't know if that's what
the fans want though I don't I don't
know I'm pretty sure the players don't
want that but I don't know what the fans
would think that would be better for the
game I mean I think we all were adapting
you know I mean it's the special thing
about you know the things I'm I'm just
I'm celebratory about the NBA is the
evolution of this game since night the
mid-80s where the game was struggling to
a multi-billion our business but has it
is it a better game it's evolved is it a
better game ah you know that's I think
that's a long-term show with about four
or five different people yeah I don't
think the game is
better now I think that they're more
talented I'm or creative but if you
watch a game where you understood what
basketball is and supposed to be if I
bring up this you know the 80s when the
Celtics are playing the Lakers
that's better basketball than today well
I you know I'm not my feeling is you
you're onto something I think the game
has plateaued a little bit but it's
still a pretty special basket but
wouldn't you take if I said you can have
the Celtics or Lakers of the mid-80s or
today's Golden State or today's
Cleveland Cavaliers I don't get me wrong
I I'd like to see Michael Jordan play
with the rules we have today I'm Joey
would average 40 right possible early in
his career when and when he was hungry
to score points probably but you know
bird all these guys I mean magic I mean
Killa these guys would have had yeah I
think we all know that it has a all know
that but I still want to give some
credence to the talented athletes that
we have today well I look at me we have
some special dudes that did yes they are
talented but the style the quality of
Aska ball is not better than what it was
players can be more talented that
doesn't mean that they play the game
better I think the topic you're
discussing is how do we make the game
better and and because of the bigness of
the game and how fast it's growing and
how much money is in the game I don't
know we've if we asked that question but
the AAU part of this the one in Dunn's
they're coming in they're talented they
don't know how to they don't know the
nuance of playing basketball I agree
the biggest diva you were ever around is
I think I'll go back all the way back to
early or my early career pride Joe Barry
Carol and I had no more most difficult
distance between how I thought the game
of basketball is played and how he
thought the game of basketball should be
played and how it should be our 49 no he
was drafted by Golden State yes the
number one overall and then that was in
McHale tree yes it made the Celtics
really good
yeah the Celtics did did quite well with
you and his nickname was Jill barely
parish yes they did straight yeah that
Red Auerbach seem to do quite well with
that
anybody else on that that comes close to
that uh uh yeah his cousin's a diva is
better than people think he is you know
he's difficult at times but he's really
I think in the end is I think he's gonna
figure it out but why does he get a bad
rap here George cuz it feels like
there's always the Kings are always on
the verge of trading DeMarcus Cousins I
have no idea you know right now I you
know I didn't like you that I you know I
I don't really take a monitor by guys
how much they like me or holla my say
dis Lee but do they play harder for you
if they like you I would probably say
some and then I say some have in an
individual pride they're gonna play at
the level they want to play at and then
there are other guys you can motivate
higher did Melo like you again that
monitor of like and dislike I think went
out of my coaching for 15-20 years so
you didn't care what about respect did
you care about respect oh yeah I think I
think I cared about how the locker room
respected the game and respected the
team and so on part of it I'm a part of
that yes and and and coach player
relationship I'm a part of respecting
them to make sure we all have a
respectful attitude towards the game of
battle tough was it to coach him Melo
yeah I don't think it was as tough as
people think it is you know it was
frustrating and the frustration is and
I've said this many times I said this
one that was coaching him he could be he
could get ten assists a game
he could get 15 rebounds a game you're
right I think he could be a damn good
defender and and he's a great scorer so
he had all the whole pack so you think
this is a choice you can blame it on you
know as a coach we never got those
buttons pushed to where he would commit
to being a triple-double star well I
wouldn't he see what LeBron is doing or
Kobe's doing or some of these other
players and say I to be more like that
to be recognized as one of the great
player he's always going to be one of
the great scorers in the game never one
of the great players one of the great
scorers
I think they're saying that you know the
thing I might answer when you asked me
that question was my mind said schooling
is easy for him and you you I think
scoring in the MBA is the hardest thing
to do it's it's really hard to score
points against defenses that are tilted
and defined to take you out and I've
seen him just score 40 on a pretty good
defensive team and that skill is
probably his comfort zone and that's
where it probably gravitates to as we
all gravitate to our comfort zones who
was the clueless GM that stands out too
well I don't know if he's clues I think
he's a very bright man but the guy that
had more and more nightmares was Wally
Walker in Seattle you guys had a pretty
good team in Seattle yeah that was fun I
mean I team too but the team started
with Bob Woodson and Mark working team
and then Bob left to go to Portland mark
left to go to Portland and gurga and I
were kind of left there in Seattle with
a volley and you know and and I thought
you know I said I mean it's it's hard to
say because you know since I don't know
since the game has grown so fast this is
where is the coach in the protocol of
power and influence in an NBA
organization you know and I you know I
like coaching I think I had my best runs
where organizations just gave me the gym
and let me coach but I think there's
been more and more infiltration of what
goes on in the gym and I'm not sure
that's good for coaching or good for the
game in basketball how crazy was Gary
Payton you know someone asked me
yesterday I have stories but they didn't
show up in the book now Gary is as
emotional as I am and it's probably
dogmatic as I am and intense as I am and
so I think we have a lot of common
things and a lot of times common people
who have a little energy to him don't
always get along and that's where I
think Gary and I started and we were we
were nose to nose
time took a while before he trusted you
at filming yeah and then it's turned
into a great relationship now it's
turned into a very special relationship
so I mean I think that's the thing we
don't have today is you know the the
trust and loyalty that hey we can work
this out
when something goes wrong it's whatever
everything pushes coaching player or
player and player or player and
management they push it apart and you
know when you coach a guy I don't know
how many times I'm Gary Payton I
probably coached 700-800 maybe 900 games
800 games I don't know how many but a
lot yeah and he's a point guard the I
that I probably put more energy into
coaching than anybody on the court
you're going to have conflict and you're
gonna have disagreement a great team
wins 50 games in the NBA a good team
wins for the games you lose 32 and then
you probably lose a playoff series along
the way so there's much there's a lot of
you know you know correction and
direction on what went wrong you can't
get close to a fight with any player
I thought maybe in the d-league and the
CBA when I was coaching the CBA there
was a couple confrontations with who
then the biggest one I remember was Ken
Johnson was a 6-8 270-pound big guy from
Michigan Machine estate or something
yeah yeah I got in a pushing mess with
him in a locker room sister picked on
the point guard do you think you want to
coach again I'm on the fence there do
you think this book will hurt you
probably you know but in the same sense
there might be someone that likes it
because I think if you read the whole
book there are things you're unlike he's
George Karl the book is furious George
why are you furious I'm frustrated I'm
think the book should be you know you
frustration it's too big you think a
furious is too long frustration is too
long the game of basketball and coaching
in the NBA today there's a lot of
frustration there's a lot of things the
coach you know when I got into coaching
that plate was small now the plate is
it's huge the things you have to take in
the things you got to interpret the
things you got to manage and on a daily
basis there's a lot of frustration and
that's why I think I think if you read
both totally completely from the
beginning to end is
I think the fans need to know the
coaches are working really hard right
rapid-fire would you rather have Phil
Jackson's coaching career or Mike
sous-chefs keys Phil would you rather
coach Larry Bird or LeBron James mm-hmm
LeBron would you rather coach Michael or
Magic Michael Bessey Tarheel oh that's
right if he went to NC State or Duke
magic
Michael Michael LeBron and pry my two
favorite best player you ever faced this
blarin toughest player to beat ever face
I'm gonna say Shaq yeah I mean I didn't
know how the game plan against jack it
was almost what would today's rules do
for Shaq would they make him better
oh yeah I think the game today
I mean if big big guys are being kind of
manipulated by a game right now yes but
a guy that can figure it out you can
shoot you can shoot a lot of dogs and he
was pretty good at thumbs yeah and
nobody wanting him try block that shot
he's George Karl the book is furious
George my 40 years surviving NBA divas
clueless GM's poor shot selection now
available online wherever books are sold
George by the way you can assess my jump
shot to this audience because this is a
full disclosure show I think it was a
compliment you said I would be an
average NBA shooter I mean when I'm
watch guys shoot and look at you for
like 30 shots younger yeah okay he's
okay I don't think I'm just gonna run
place for you
I like your fingers look you got good
fingers who would you compare me to
whether you coach them or their I coach
the guy in the dealing in the CBA no
wait wait wait don't go d-league I'm in
the only player I think he made you late
for a little bit but you haven't shut
your feet act like your jumper looks
like Doug Lee from Purdue University
yeah that's not a compliment oh you want
to compliment well I want you to be
honest here right Craig Ehlo all right
that's fair enough okay yeah yeah I play
crazy that was average you played the
court game because the D
yeah I don't play D but his jump shot
got to be average or maybe a little
better I'm an average NBA shooter NBA
wise which would make me a better than
average college shooter and make me an
unbelievable shooter with everybody else
in the world
your your your your loyal staff says you
can make the three oh I think they're on
that's my dojo that's where I make my
living the three is I might step up a
little bit if I can see you can make the
three then you make ten in a row from
the three eight out of ten if you go
around the horn five five five thirty
five somebody run out of the main five
shots I may run out of breath yeah thank
you George for coming in okay Dan all
right the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]